pour l'équipe de chez tousignant
la recette bon burger n'a plus de secret
cela commence avec une boulette de boeuf
haché maison ni maigre c'est à dire ne
contenant pas plus de 23 % de gras dans
le gras beaucoup de saveurs qui quand la
viande et les quads dans une veine
quelque chose s'est fait que le groupe
va rester dans la viande et ça va venir
car analyser la viande qui s'appelle
l'effet maillard c'est ce qu'ont gâché à
chaque jour ne vient pour l'utiliser des
muscles entier donc on a quand même un
taux de viande et de gros j'ai quand
même parfait parce que on est vraiment
en compte qu'ils ont venir h et une fois
et une fois uniquement
[Musique]
le boeuf haché qu'on se procure en
épicerie provient généralement des
boucheries centralisée des bannières est
fait à partir de parures de viande comme
nous l'expliquent ce professeur en
boucherie si on parle de la base un
boeuf haché ça bien de quelle partie du
boeuf le boeuf haché c'est un petit peu
un des petits morceaux de tous qu'on
récupère pendant le débitage pendant le
désossage de l'animal puis d'après le
morceau qu'on travaille mais ça va
arriver que des fois le morceau voit
beaucoup plus gros et on voit le mettre
dans la partie du mail puis les partis
qui sont très très très bon et on va les
mettre dans l'extra mais c'est comme ça
qu'on va jouer avec la viande hachée
c'est sûr qu'on ne sait quel extrêmement
que c'est 10 % de matière grasse au
maximum après ça le mec c 17 % de
matière grasse maximum bien sûr et le
minx et 23 pour ça et l'ordonnancé 30
pour ça généralement à l'heure on peut
mieux le voir avec les petits picots
grenet terre la couleur de du haché qui
va sortir de la tête brûlée en 2016
l'épicerie avait fait analysé en
laboratoire
trente six échantillons de boeuf haché
provenant de quatre grandes chaînes dans
treize magasins
tous les échantillons respecter les
normes mais étonnamment 40% des viandes
étaient bons et grâce cas fichiers on a
quand même une marge de manoeuvre
on a quand même environ 10% de l'extrême
souvent on va peut-être la porsche et +
5 % pour la même chose pour les autres
c'est si les mimiques d'inco dire on est
reproché le 23 pour ça on va peut-être
plus à l'est vers le pain pour ce 1 19%
pourrais-tu de pas trop le dépasser
bien sûr il est difficile pour le
consommateur de faire la différence à
l'oeil
entre chaque grade en achetant la viande
contente d'uniformiser la couleur et la
texture on le h comme ça une fois et on
repense une deuxième fois pour que les
greens de viande ne redevienne plus en
plus petits qui met souvent dans les
industries vont passer une troisième
fois
parce que les gens quand ils voient des
petits picots blanc à l'intérieur d'une
grange et généralement ils vont aussi up
si kruger
on n'en veut pas tandis que quand c'est
bien mélanger la demande est plus long
que des gens en vie nous avons demandé à
me caler de faire cuire pour nous trois
boulettes de boeuf
donc on a notre viande hachée extra
maigre notre viande maigre et nimègue
nous pourrons ainsi constater les
différences une fois culte donc se voit
que beaucoup d'eau qui vient de sortir
c'est extra maigre donc il y en a pas
grand
puis quand on voit des jus comme ça ce
n'est pas du sein ok c'est de l'autre on
a quand même une belle croûte mais
personnellement je le sais que ça va
être vraiment quelque chose qui va cette
embauche celui là y a plus de grands qui
voit mind que ya plus de gorilles du jeu
qui vient de sortir médecin cassard
isole un petit peu plus que les autres
de plus ce coup siens en entend bien on
est en train de bouillir ici tout le
voit ici un peu moins
pisi à presque rien du tout parce que
y'a de ce grave
on note bien extrait mecque et on a
perdu quand même quand on ait pu
constater que chaque boulette a perdu le
même poids principalement en haut le
dernier
il ya quand même encore convaincu l'on
voit ces accords juteux c'est 100 g donc
il ya plus de grave mais tout les
niveaux d'eau sont sortis lui il ya
gardé plus de sons grâce et juteux mais
si on s'en va ici puis celle là on n'a
pas coupé
enfin c'est sec c'est ce que c'est que
ce petit chat est un gars sait c'est que
six ex exactement
[Musique]
après cuisson votre boulettes de boeuf
haché extra maigre beau coûtera environ
15 % plus cher qu'une me maigre
si vous voulez faire un pain de viande
vous voulez avoir un routine cuisson
plus grosse mais on a besoin gras à
l'intérieur parce que sinon même en
devenir c'est qd tu es moi je trouve
toujours que du gros sel importante
donc j'ai besoin de gras mais à
l'extrême boeuf haché extra maigre je
fais quoi avec ça vous pouvez faire
l'état qu'on pouvait faire cuire à la
pointe mélange 5 des légumes pour faire
un petit mélange avec un sauté des yeux
il est généralement l'extrême importance
pour ne pas avoir de gros le moins
possible pour pas avoir trop de liquide
dans combat poids non plus où pourtant
nous reste souvent l'extrême que ça va
être pour son pour mélanger avec
d'autres ingrédients
donc si on veut manger vaut mieux
d'aller avec me mettre qu'un mec ou un
extrait mais juste parce que le grade
c'est quand même la saveur du goût qui
savent attendre de jute le stena line
[Musique]